ANNIE JEAN-BAPTISTE:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Annie Jean-Baptiste,
and I lead product inclusion
at Google.
Product inclusion is all about
bringing an inclusive lens
throughout the product
design process,
and I'm excited to share
a little bit about how
we've been doing that.
First, I just want to
welcome you to the session.
This may be a newer
concept for you,
and so I hope that it's helpful.
But I'm super
excited that you're
spending the time to learn
about product inclusion today.
Before we get started, I
just wanted to level set
and have a shared framework
around what we mean
when we say product inclusion.
Product inclusion is about
building, designing, coding
for everyone.
So no matter who you are, where
you live, what you look like,
we want to make sure
that you feel thought
of in the entire
product design process
and when you pick up
a product or service.
And so at Google,
we want to make
sure that we're bringing
that inclusive lens
throughout everything
that we create.
So the first thing that's
really important to think about
is really, how this ties
back into Google's mission.
And so we talk about organizing
the world's information
and making it universally
accessible and useful.
It's really the universal
piece that we're leaning
into in product inclusion.
And we say not just
for some, for everyone.
So I talked a little bit
about some dimensions
that we think of, but it's
really important to make sure
that everyone is thought
of in the process
and especially,
those who have been
historically underrepresented
in the product design process.
Now this work builds on a
lot of great work, namely
accessibility work and
Next Billion Users work.
What happens with
product inclusion
is that we actually look at
12 dimensions of diversity
and the intersections
of those dimensions.
What I mean when I
say the intersections
of those dimensions is that
users aren't in a silo.
They don't have one thing
that makes them who they are.
And so it's really
important to think
about everything
holistically when you're
building products or services.
Using myself as an
example, I'm a black woman.
I'm also left-handed.
I'm not black on Monday,
a woman on Tuesday,
and left-handed on Wednesday.
All of those things
are encompassed
within me, affect how I
move through the world,
and definitely affect
how I use products.
And so we want to make sure
that we're thinking holistically
about all of those dimensions
when we're building.
So on this slide, you're
seeing a few of the dimensions
that we look at.
Again, we look at 12.
But things like gender,
age, ability, education,
socioeconomic status,
and more are really
integral into making sure
that you're asking, who else?
And really broadening who your
users could and should be.
It's also really
important to note
that there's a lot of
untapped opportunity
when you bring an inclusive
lens and really center
those who have been
historically underrepresented.
So what you're
seeing on this slide
are a bunch of statistics around
things like purchasing power,
digital usage for a
lot of the historically
underrepresented
groups that we focus on
with product inclusion.
So you can see stats as it
relates to accessibility.
There 1 billion people in
the world with a disability--
for example.
Or you can look at 700
million users coming
online in the next few years.
It's really exciting that
there's so much opportunity
when you bring an
inclusive lens,
and that can really
affect your business
and being able to
serve even more users.
It's important to note that
product inclusion is not just
one point in your process.
It's really throughout
the process.
And the earlier that you
bring it in, the better.
So you can bring
it in an ideation,
for example, when
you're starting
to think of a product
or service that may
have an untapped opportunity.
But what's really important
is to highlight and understand
what key points in
the process you're
going to bring that
inclusive lens.
We call those inflection points.
And on this slide, you can see
there are multiple inflection
points where we started to
bring that inclusive lens
throughout the process.
And the goal is that
the end result is
more inclusive of more people.
So next, I'm just going to
jump into a few case studies
to help you understand what our
product inclusion journey looks
like, and how this can
actually be put into action.
So this first video
is from a team
that worked on camera sensors.
And what they wanted
to do was really
ensure that they brought
this inclusive lens
and ensured all skin tones
were accurately represented.
What I love about this is that
it shows that no matter where
you are in the organization,
you have a part
to play in building for
everyone and with everyone.
So with that, we'll
roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Pictures tell stories.
It doesn't really
matter if it's a selfie
or if it's a portrait
that somebody
is taking of another person.
You are sharing in
that human moment.
- take a picture of you two.
1, 2, 3.
No, he's too dark.
- So this is where the
discussion started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Here, just use my phone.
It's got a better sensor.
- A better sensor?
What does that even mean?
- Color chaining is an
extremely complicated process.
When we look at images,
what we try to do
is figure out how
much of a difference
there is between, let's
say, a reference image
and the image that we actually
are trying to quantify.
We were running some
tests on a product,
and it was the proximity
sensor we were testing.
And we said, oh, it looks
like it does 60 centimeters.
And we looked to each other,
and we go, we're both white.
The technology itself, as many
people will say, is not racist.
It's just that it
wasn't tested properly
to make sure that the designers
weren't unconsciously biased.
Hey, there's an entire
world out there,
and we want to make sure
this works for everybody.
I love the fact that we
get to influence cameras.
And we get to share
those experiences
of life and emotion.
And, to me, that is
what imaging is about.
It as a vehicle to
express humanity.
- Take a picture of you two.
1, 2, 3.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNIE JEAN-BAPTISTE:
The next case study
I'd like to show you is
with Duo Low Light Mode.
What Duo Low Light
team did was be
intentional about bringing
diverse perspectives
to the table from the
beginning of their process.
At Google, we have what we
call inclusion champions, who
are Googlers from across the
globe in multiple dimensions
of diversity, who have
helped us dog food
or user test our products.
So the Duo Low
Light mode team knew
that they wanted to make
sure that no matter where
you were in the world or
if you had certain lighting
or you had light
or dark skin tones,
you were going to be
accurately represented
when using this video product.
And so, they worked with
our inclusion champions
to make sure that we tested
across multiple dimensions
of diversity.
To make sure that, again,
everyone feels beautifully
and accurately
represented and thought
of when they use the product.
Now I'll go into a little
bit of the research
that we've been doing over
the past year on the business
case for inclusion.
I hope it's helpful
to start to frame what
users and consumers are thinking
about as it relates to products
inclusion, but also how you
can start to implement it
in your everyday work.
So the first piece of data
that I wanted to share with you
all is that there are four
places in the product design
process where it's
really important
to bring that inclusive lens.
Those four points are the
ideation, user research, user
testing, and marketing phases.
Now a few slides
back, I showed you
an end-to-end product
inclusion process
slide, where you saw
multiple inflection points,
or points in the process
where you could bring product
inclusion into the fold.
That being said, when we
did research and looked
at a bunch of different teams
across Google, what we found
was that these are the four
points where teams constantly
came back to.
And also, these
were the four points
where if you did bring
an inclusive lens
and were intentional
about doing so,
you actually
disproportionately created
a more inclusive product.
And so we encourage
you all to think about
if these four points
in the process
make sense for
your organization,
and how you can bring that
inclusive lens to those four
points.
It's also important to just
start to ask, who else?
So, for example,
if you're starting
to ideate within
your organization,
maybe bring someone from another
piece of the organization
or another team into
the brainstorming
because they'll likely have
different perspectives.
If you're already
doing user research,
maybe you do user
research internationally
or with a different demographic
than you usually do.
These small changes can
lead to really big results
as it relates to bringing
that inclusive lens.
The second piece was
that 100% of teams
that brought an inclusive
lens into their process
did so at least two of the four
touch points I just mentioned.
So either the ideation,
user research, user testing,
or marketing phases,
they did at least two.
So it may be the ideation and
marketing or the user research
and user testing.
But they made sure
that it wasn't just
an isolated point in time,
but that they were doing it
throughout the process.
And I think that that's
really important.
Not only because you're
starting to think holistically
about your process, but also
you can involve different team
members and different
organization members who
have different
expertise to, again,
start to bring more perspectives
that have historically been
underrepresented into the fold.
Another key finding was
that both underrepresented
and majority groups prefer
inclusive marketing and product
design.
What does that mean?
It's been a notion that only
underrepresented groups want
to see themselves reflected.
And what we found is that
that's actually not true.
Everyone, or the
majority of people,
want to see diversity
and inclusion,
both in marketing
and storytelling,
but also in product design.
And so I think that
that's a big shift
that we want to make
sure that we think about.
It's not just those who
have been historically
underrepresented,
but it's actually
underrepresented in the
majority consumers or users.
The last finding that I'd
like to share with you all
is that teams, no matter
their representation,
that were intentional about
bringing an inclusive lens
were able to do so.
So regardless of the
team makeup-- and we
talk a lot about the
systemic changes that
need to happen in order to have
representation and inclusive
culture, that is
incredibly important still.
But even as you're working to
get to that representation,
you can start to work on
product inclusion now.
So regardless of the makeup,
if you're setting standards,
if you're holding yourself
and your team accountable,
you can actually
start to make headway
in building that
inclusive product.
So now I'm just going to
go through three principles
that we help to guide teams
along their product inclusion
journey.
The first one is to
address the user.
So I showed you a few
of the 12 dimensions
that we focus on as it
relates to product inclusion.
But really, thinking
about what dimensions
have been underrepresented
in your process,
and bringing those
into the fold.
You want to address the users.
Again, asking, who else?
And continuing to
expand the pool who uses
could and should be.
The second one is to
start with equity.
So inclusion shouldn't
be an afterthought.
It's not something that comes
in after you've actually
created everything.
How can you bring it in
earlier on in the process
and at multiple
points in the process?
Again, this doesn't
sit within one team.
It sits within all parts
of the organization.
And so, how are you
making sure that you
found those key process points.
And you've brought the
key stakeholders in
to help move that along.
And the last one is
to continually test.
So just like any other part of
your product design process,
this needs to be iterative.
You want to make sure that you
aren't just checking a box,
but you're constantly shifting.
You're constantly improving.
You're constantly
getting feedback, just
like any other part of your
product design process.
You want to make sure
that you're learning,
you're growing, and you're
bringing more voices
into the fold, and
you're adapting
as you're getting feedback.
So this, just like any
other part of your process,
you want to commit to.
You want to have standards and
accountability frameworks for.
And you want to constantly,
constantly be improving.
And so with that, thank you so
much for joining the product
inclusion session.
I hope it was helpful,
and have a great day.
Thanks so much.